BEN MORRIS: Hey, I'm Ben
Morris from the AMP Team.
We're live here at AMP
Conference 2018 right
here in Amsterdam.
It's been a big day full of
some exciting announcements,
some major news.
Let's see some of
the highlights.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Today we're launching
both a developer preview
on AMP site, and
there's going to be
surfacing of these
stories in Google Search.
SPEAKER 2: So I'm also really
excited to announce today
that we're releasing the
AMP-Toolbox-Optimizer which
is basically a tool
kit that developers
can use to optimize
AMP documents served
from their origin.
SPEAKER 1: I'm super
excited to announce that AMP
is, in fact, coming to email.
SPEAKER 3: So imagine that
you could complete tasks
directly inside of your email.
So with AMP for email,
users can quickly
take actions on things
like RSVPing to an event.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 4: Now, as we do with
many new experimental features
in AMP, we have
collaborated with publishers
to help innovate in this space
with the goal of building
a storage format for
rich storytelling.
SPEAKER 3: By
bringing AMP to email,
we open up a whole new
world of possibilities
for what can happen
inside of email
and a whole world of
possibilities for users
to engage with your content.
SPEAKER 2: So one of
the biggest initiatives
has been to expand AMP
experiences from just
organic to paid as well.
And last year, the
[INAUDIBLE] team
launched their AMP experience
where clicking on ads
will now lead you to AMP pages.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 5: Overall development
time and workflow was just way
easier having the full
AMP site and just the one
source of truth for the site.
So for example,
bringing it back again
to my time working on
Buzzfeed, the article pages,
comparing it to Tasty, the
bill time we see 85% faster
build time, the webpack build.
SPEAKER 6: Well, we
want to allow all of you
to write JavaScript
in AMP documents.
So, all this JavaScript will
run in a web world grid.
BEN MORRIS: And those
were some highlights
from day one of AMP Conf.
To see more of the
talks in more detail,
just to subscribe to
the AMP Channel and tune
in tomorrow for live
coverage of day two.
Thanks a lot.